[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
uh great guest coming up he's never been
on the show i've worked with him you
know him from smallville we'll get into
that but some
uh some important stuff i'd like to
share with you get a little personal
it's been a crazy week uh my dog irv
went to the hospital
uh i woke up he was fine the night
before um just a couple nights ago
uh you ryan you know the story yeah and
um
he woke up and he was able to he was
limping a little bit and barely moving
and i was like
well you know he has leg problems
because he's old and all this stuff so i
thought you know maybe he slept on it
wrong
certainly i wake up and limp around
stubbed my toe
uh took him up to pee and poop and all
that stuff and then that was that
thus began the downfall and um
he just lied next to the dining room
table and i was like something's wrong
he wasn't eating and then i i put these
booties on him right so i took off the
booty and i know his paw was twice
the size of the other and there was a
little pus
and i said he's got an infection and he
felt really warm and i'm not a doctor
but i was like
i've gotta go to the hospital i called
up my friend rob thankfully it was on a
sunday
and he raced over he thought it wasn't
gonna be a big deal and then when he saw
earth i could see the shock on his face
because he knew i was freaking out
we carried irv he was limp i'm talking
jello like this dog was not moving and i
was like i have to hurry we carry him to
the car
he defecated all over us i mean there
was [ __ ] everywhere
uh you know i did the best i could but i
was on the move
uh we'll clean that problem later um we
drove to the hospital i said rob listen
man
trust me but i'm good i'm going through
every stoplight
and i went through every stoplight to
the hospital got him there they came out
and i was trying to keep it together and
i was like
keep him away keep him awake his tongue
was hanging out of his mouth
i knew like oh my god this is uh
am i gonna lose my dog i i don't know if
i could deal with this right now uh
and i took him there and i you know
you're not supposed to go in the place
but i opened the door hey my dog is
dying can
someone please uh get a stretcher
i really need help and they raced out
there the people at access hospital in
culver city
were enormous and uh put him on a
stretcher
and i went in with him just petting him
and saying hey buddy it's all right
looking at him going oh my god is this
the last time i want to see my dog
and he went in and i went around the
corner where rob my friend rob wasn't
and i just bawled i just let it out man
and i was emotional i was just really
raw emotions
i've had him for a long time he's the
only person i've lived with
you know and um and we stayed there for
a couple hours and we ordered food in
the
parking lot rob was a good friend and um
is a good friend and you know the doctor
called and said hey his temperature's
down a little bit
we're running um antibiotics through
them fluids through them
and then i finally went home and they
said he's definitely staying the night
in the hospital and
i finally get a call and i'm calling
them you know
incessantly just like you know and i
mean that's what you do i think
you know i didn't feel bad about doing
it but and i wasn't hearing back and i
called you know because they were
you know they're busy they're i mean
you've seen other dogs go in there it's
a hospital you know things are happening
and i'm like well either he's just not
that bad
hoping and then the doctor called me um
and said hey his temperature's gone down
fluids
he's he actually went he stood up
and he started slowly getting better i
kept him there for another night went to
see him the next day
kept him there another night took him
home and um
i called jess my friend jess and she
just came over and she's been helping
and
just cleaning it is you know he had an
abscess
so if your dog starts crapping or
not eating or you feel his head dogs
have a higher temperature
so his was like a 106 i think
and uh man i thought i was gonna lose
him so i was
i thought i was just gonna get a little
emotional talking about this but look
the good news is he's he's
he's much better he's walking around
he's taking tons of pills i mean the
regimen he's on
and then of course little [ __ ] blanche
uh my puppy
she's uh she's got these bumps on her
back i'm like what the [ __ ] and she had
an infection it wasn't like a bad
infection but she had to be an
antibiotic so i took her
so it's just been i've probably been to
15 to 20 vets hospitals
pts in the last three weeks and you know
i called my friend tom and dineen and
they're like hey what's up and i was
just like
i'm just i'm overwhelmed and i usually
don't
talk about me being overwhelmed unless
i'm talking to my
listeners or my patrons or you but it's
funny in my personal life i don't really
something i don't allow i don't want to
burden people everyone's going through
their own [ __ ] but i was really in a
tough place and
um i'm just i'm just thankful that i
have
i get to see him again and i get to hang
out with him and i know he's old
my friend harlan funny story harlan you
know from uh
something about mary drinking and
something grandpa's cough medicine are
you buddy
dumb and dumber he was on that something
about mary uh sorority boys with me
good friend any and every time something
happens to her if he always leaves a
message hey bud i'm so sorry uh
you know uh maybe it's the time to like
say goodbye you know maybe put him to
sleep or
i'm like harland he has an infection
last time you know he's he went blind
yeah maybe it's time no it's not
so i make this joke now i i send
messages like hey erf stubbed his toe
so i'm thinking about he's like okay
he's like hey buddy i wasn't i was just
saying you know he's old i'm like yeah
but just because he's old you don't some
old guy says you know all of a sudden
i've got
uh i fell you don't put him to sleep
anyway so sorry there you have it thanks
man uh good friends
everybody uh it's too hard i suggest if
anything ever happens to you guys and
inevitably it will send an email to all
your loved ones
at the same time and just say i will
keep you updated i'm not going to
respond to messages because it's too
much
yeah and so i just sent a picture i sent
little things and everybody was really
supportive and
irv's doing great so thanks for
everybody out there even fans my patrons
just
sending love and uh you know
it's uh it's been an emotional time and
this you adding the whole pandemic
adding all these things of course
you know you don't know how stressed you
are and [ __ ] up you are effed up
until it hits you and then it hit me so
um
there you go i'm glad he's okay yeah
thanks man uh
hey big shout out guys big announcement
right now you're hearing it first
uh it's in the trades but first time i
had a chance ryan uh westwood one bought
the show
exciting stuff yeah man we've been
talking about it for a long time and i'm
just so
pumped that we have a big uh company
that's letting us
do our show the way we do it from my
home
it's like there's no interference other
than just incredible support
and uh there's so many i wish i could
name all of them but i'm doing i'm
having meetings now
i never had meetings it's just like you
know so
uh it's just it's really amazing to have
someone behind your show that could
really
um help you and help the show get out to
more listeners and people who might
uh benefit from listening and enjoy it
so i want to say thank you to everybody
for attending our stage at show rob and
i if you go to stage.com we did two
shows on saturday online show it was
tremendous people are amazing we do
zooms and prizes and it's uh
thank you to all the patrons and uh uh
yeah it's just incredible and we're
making a lot of good music and rob on
your shirt is that the two you guys oh
yeah this is the uh
new band shirt they're available at uh
rosenbaumandanson.com and go to catalog
and women's v-necks and all that [ __ ]
and men's
um i don't want to be that guy that gets
a sound i hate that
i don't want to become that guy uh i'll
be doing some virtual cons
i just did one it was really awesome and
so check the instagram and all that we
do zooms and
tom welling and i from small but we do
some zooms with people and uh thanks to
all the patrons again
for the support and all the amazingness
uh right now this this guest is like
i've been trying to get him and he's the
hardest guest well there's one other
guest on the
on smallville that i i couldn't get but
anyway it was funny because
if you watch if you're watching this if
you're listening you should probably
watch it too
john's shirtless and uh you know i
really appreciated him being shirtless
because he's got a great body
he's uh you know when i get to be his
age which is not you know not that too
far away uh but he's working on his uh
he's got a studio down in louisiana
and uh it's louisiana right it was
louisiana
and uh he's working so we go a little
from location to location because of
sound but
uh ryan here did an incredible job
piecing it together and it's really
interesting because he gets personal
talks about
the lawsuit going to jail uh his new
studios new life the new love of his
life
scares with his his wife with dealing
with cancer but also
uh some fun stuff and uh really
interesting story and i really really uh
i love you john thanks for opening up
and being so
sweet so you know i'm from smallville
duke's a hazard
having have nots there's just so many
things he's done let's get inside john
schneider
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
where where where are you louisiana in
louisiana at john schneider studios
um we have 150 acres or so here
uh actually i don't have it that's a
whole other long story but um
it's uh it's a beautiful place
uh just hey folks just before we got on
the air here
uh i was showing michael the pool this
used to be a summer camp
uh from like 1940 until 1990
it was either a summer camp or a church
camp so it's got this most amazing pool
it's 200 and something thousand gallons
and uh when people rent the place to
to shoot movies and do different things
they wind up invariably hanging out at
the pool and having a great time so i
showed michael and he went
yeah and he's also what he's insinuating
really is that you're all welcome
to come down and hang out in his pool
he'd love that well yeah
you know we have uh airbnb here too so
you know you can't come for free
but you can come down and uh for you
know a couple of pennies
well i'll tell you what i'll pay
whatever money if you promise to have
your shirt off
if i come there ah i was working i was
working when uh
when this happened is either take your
call or run to the house and get another
shirt but i figured this would be okay
look i said this before your first
shirtless guess it is
it's the first shirtless guest and by
the way i gotta say
i looked up you know obviously i don't
know how old you are i never would have
thought 60 years old
ever i don't know how you look this good
i always say this like
my mom said it my aunt said it or my
friend said like he's really hot
when we were doing smallville and i'm
like okay thanks all right well oh thank
you i don't know what to say but i'll
tell them oh
thank you thanks but thank you
i'm happy you are happy and by the way
someone who has like
you know i know you're writing a book i
know you're doing all these i mean
you've done everything
we'll get into that but dude i wrote the
book i wrote the book the book is out
the book is that now my life's my way
yeah it's out now my life my way get on
amazon why not
do you tell all the truths no the next
one i tell the truth yeah but i get the
next one is called uh
uh naked so the next one will be uh
they'll be a little bit more uh
darker and depth as far as into the dark
stuff you know because i'm
i write dark things so uh when uh
when naked comes out they'll be a little
more uh the first one is absolutely true
but the first one is like
um
you know so that people will go oh
that's cool i didn't know that oh i
didn't know
you know the divorce is in there losing
the studios and all that stuff is in
there but it's
it's uh it's more with the smile
uh it's more of a uh
light at the end of the tunnel and then
the second one is going to be a little
bit of
finding out that the light at the end of
the tunnel is attached to the front of a
train
but you know like you look a lot of
actors and people think oh look i'm
successful
i bet they were popular in high school i
bet they had it all they just always
have been lucky and
talented and they have whatever it is
and so like on my podcast i like to find
out things that sort
of make people human make people others
relate
and say oh wow he suffered from and you
think oh john schneider i mean obviously
we've had some hardships which we can
get into but
when you were in high school you were
you were overweight to say the least
right i was the fat kid
yeah i was the uh if if i was in if i
was a character in sandlot it would be
the fat kid with the inhaler
you know you had an inhaler i had an
inhaler primateen
mist i remember it well i was you know
the last guy kind of chugging along at
track and field you had to take track in
new york i'm from new york new york
state right
but um yeah there was there was
something though michael when i when i
uh i used to go to the movies uh every
saturday
um and i would i would go to a double
feature and i would sit there
and it would i don't know how to
describe the difference i get into this
in
in my life my way but i would look up
there and go
not that's gee that's where i want to be
but i look up there and
go that's where i'm supposed to be
that's that's where i'm going to be
um but it wasn't like wishful thinking
there was something
something in me from about eight years
old on
that said this is what you were built
to do this this is why you are here
um so i never when when uh
when kids would uh pick on me
and you know push me they did they used
to do this wonderful thing in new york
where one guy would get your attention
and the other guy would
get on his hands and knees behind you
and then they would they would tip you
over and do a pile of dog [ __ ]
that was that was that was fun stuff
they did in new york state
um so when things like that would happen
i would i would think well that's all
right that's okay you know
they probably picked on john wayne
because his name was marion
his name was mary marion john wayne
marion
michael morrison so um there was there
was never a
point now granted dukes of hazard
happened when i was 18
but it happened when i was 18 because
i'd already done
10 years of theater um i was already on
the
on the path i was already trajectory
pretty much
unstoppable um
which is why i walked into the audition
for dukes with a six-pack of beer and i
i gave them what i thought they wanted
and i was right
so what beer was it john papp's blue
ribbon bbr
do you remember uh what was it uh the
david lynch movie he's like
heineken [ __ ] that [ __ ] paps blue
ribbon pbr baby yeah what was that uh um
david lynch was uh blue velvet blue
velvet you're right what can i say
so john i mean you're you're overweight
you're 250 pounds people are making
funnier
but you see something that no one else
sees you see almost
i guess your future in a way right yeah
well it was um
when i was a kid i love the television
show i love the television show uh lost
in space
right and i had a weird dream that they
were shooting lost in space
at my dad's upholstery shop and i was
like
10. so i didn't have a dream that i was
in you know on the jupiter 2 with the
robinson family i had a dream they were
filming
at my dad's shop and there was uh there
were lights and there was a clapperboard
and all that but there was there was
craft service
how in the world would i know there was
such thing as craft service
on a television show set i was going to
make a fat joke but i'm not going to do
it yeah yeah yeah about craft service
yeah but hey hey hollywood
but um they were there and i was sitting
talking with the with billy mummy
or mummy i'm not sure uh yeah and
we were just we were pals i wasn't with
will robinson so it was weird i had a
couple of things like that happen in my
uh
in my life later on i i ran into june
lockhart
who was in the dream too had a weird
dream that uh
i was at a party in a tuxedo and i
bumped into somebody and i said oh
excuse me
the guy turned around it was dean martin
and dean martin also in a tuxedo like he
always was said to me
thanks for having me here and i'm like
11 years old right
and uh years later during
uh one of the the last children's
miracle network we did at videopolis out
at disneyland there
um i i was wearing my tuxedo and i
bumped into it to a gentleman i said oh
excuse me turned around it's dean martin
and he says thanks for having me here
so when opportunities come around like
dukes of hazzard when opportunities come
around like smallville which i said no
emphatically i said i don't want to be
part of the demise of the superman
legend i don't want to have anything to
do with small
bill you really turn to just turn it
down three times
wow i turned down the audition i said
i'm not gonna go audition
i'm not gonna take the no and then uh
then they said just read the pilot my my
agent said read the pilot
and i got to the part where uh
where uh i have the keys to the truck
that you gave uh
you gave clark on the wall and i i said
um
he said so you're saying the apple
doesn't fall far from the tree and i
said no
i said i just want you to realize where
the money came from that bought that
truck
and at that point i knew that that this
was not going to be the demise of
superman this was going to be something
that would firmly plant superman into
the psyche of watchers forever
that it in fact would be the best part
of the superman legend
um and at that point i i it wasn't like
oh gosh
i want to be jonathan kent it was like
oh
this is the next thing this is the next
stepping stone for me um
so i didn't have any doubt in the world
that i was going to get it
even though there were there were other
people there and i i
and somehow michael somehow this is not
uh
it's not arrogance it's like seeing it
when i was 18 and i read dukes of
hazzard
i thought oh this is it
this is the springboard what i've been
working toward
uh gosh it's hard to explain no no i
absolutely understand it listen to me
there are some people
who think and you know i think i've been
both these people
that you're like this is me this is the
role i'm getting this role and then
there are a lot of people who think
oh my gosh but they're going to go out
to somebody else there's going to be so
many other people there but
you know you start thinking there's a
certain confidence and i think
certain um inadvertent i don't know if
it's inadvertent but it's it's it's
this brave sort of
intuition or feeling you get when you're
younger and you're
like excited about something i remember
in college saying to alexis combs
i remember her name sitting on the porch
and i go i'm gonna go to new york and
i'm gonna make it and she's like oh
okay she didn't talk like that she was
way smarter than me i don't know why i
made it i just i try to differentiate my
voice she was just like
okay oh great michael that's great and
by the way uh
we we've texted in the last six months
and um
but i said no no no no i'm going to new
york
i know the odds i know all that stuff it
it it doesn't
it's not that's not about me i know what
i'm gonna do so there was a certain
and i go remember this moment because
you're gonna go oh my god i remember him
saying that because i felt it
it was just something i felt so i
understand that you had this feeling
that this is going to happen
yeah well you know you have to um they
say that success is when preparation
meets opportunity
right but there's another part to that
um i know a lot of very talented people
that that throw opportunity away with
both hands because they don't recognize
it
you've got to recognize you have to
expect
great things if you don't expect
great things if you look at you look at
life like ah [ __ ] what's going to happen
now
nothing is going to happen now certainly
nothing good but if you look at life
like i get like a little kid there's an
easter egg you know where's the easter
egg
i know there's an easter egg out here
because because they're supposed to be
so if you look at life that way then you
start recognizing the easter eggs
and you start realizing what you have
prepared for so
prep of success is when preparation
meets
opportunity that you recognize uh and
you recognize it when you expect it
so um when i first saw this property
where
where the studio is now i came in and it
was like i saw i saw nothing but
opportunity here i saw my god i could we
could shoot this we could shoot that
we could film here we can build a barn
we can put on a play we've done
all those corny things you saw it that
yeah
that that that 13 year olds want to do
when they uh
when they get together and they're going
to do the odd couple you know let's do a
let's do a play that we only have uh
we only have one room so they go and
they do the odd couple
right and uh that's that's what i live
here
every day alicia and i have made 11
movies michael
11. we've been together it'll be six
years in october
and uh we've made 11 films when i saw
you in the
uh at the good neighbor i have to plug
them because it's my favorite little
breakfast place in the world in uh
studio city sort of north hollywood i
saw you there and it's the first time
i'd seen you in a long time you were
sitting there with her
i remember you looked at me and you go
i'm really happy
and it made me and so and just i felt so
warm inside i
just felt so good that you felt that way
and i could see it
and um you know when you just said
you are happy i i could see that there's
something about you
that it's not saying that you weren't
necessarily happy in the past when i saw
you
but now when i there's a certain glow
where i think
i think you said this on the phone when
we were when i was trying to get you to
do this podcast and you said something
like
uh she lets me be me i could be myself
something along those lines right yeah
well and also you know uh
uh one of the greatest lines of dialogue
ever was
she makes me want to be a better man
right
hey let me ask you what when you i mean
look you go from a kid who's
uh you know an overweight kid who uh you
know suddenly gets this confidence
uh supposedly i read about is it true
that your your brother
you you found a hundred bucks under a
video game and you took that and you
went to the gym with it is that true
i did yeah i did but hey i gotta back
you up a little bit
because um even when i was a the fat kid
i still had the confidence
you know so it was uh an unusual
combination i had the uh
denver pyle said uh
i had the strength of my ignorance
you know i i didn't know it was
impossible
so i did it i think it's important it's
like it's nice to see that
you sort of knew who you were then in a
way you know where i i'm still figuring
it out but like you were like i don't
care and that's what i'd like to say
you know i have a family members or
friends that you know are overweight or
or don't like this about themselves i
don't like things about myself but i'm
like
just learn to love yourself i mean
that's what we have to all do
and you see it seems like you had
confidence in yourself and you
loved yourself and you're ready to go to
the next level well i believe
michael that we're here for some reason
you know we aren't just we aren't just
around uh we aren't just taking up space
um that there is something we're
supposed to do
everybody not just me not just you but
everybody
and i think my grandmother put that
instilled that into me
um and that's a lot of that
i think i passed on in a very real sense
to
in in smallville jonathan to clark
you know you're here for something um
so do it so you're not here to be a
a failure you're not here to be a uh
a problem you're here to do something
good for someone else
and i knew that so as a as a kid i knew
well yeah i'm overweight and i
i did have to make a decision which my
brother helped me make
uh my brother one day after my like
third slice of pizza at six flags said
so i guess you've just forgotten all
about that movie star thing huh
and i said boom what do you mean they
said well how many fat
movie stars do you know and at that
point all i could think of was zero
mostel and i i knew i wasn't
made to be zero mostel john candy john
belushi
well not at that point this was uh i
don't know i don't think uh did saturday
night live happen in 76
75 sure maybe think so so i
when you're on a path and you hear
somebody tell you
the truth that will steer you
in the right direction uh you recognize
it again that's that opportunity
recognizing that opportunity
so i had the opportunity to either
continue eating the pizza
or stop because he was right
uh but who i was up to that point was
the fat kid who
made up for not being able to run in
track by having a guitar on my back and
playing music
for everybody all the time in high
school so i wasn't an unpopular guy
i was kind of that guy with the guitar
that would would sing those
jim croche songs um
but that stopped as soon as my brother
said that that stopped the next day
we were at a bowling alley and i was
playing the an evil knievel
pinball machine i dropped a quarter
i crawled underneath the machine to get
the quarter and i found
dollar bill across the street it sounds
like it sounds like fiction
across the street from the bowling alley
was a big sign
nautilus had just opened up the first
nautilus i think anywhere
and it was three years for a hundred
dollars
so i that night i asked my mom you know
what should i do
and she said well if you're really gonna
do this movie star
thing then you should spend your hundred
dollars so i did i spent my hundred
dollars
and uh two months later i was uh 185
pounds
and looked great uh because i'd spent
two months dieting and working out at
nautilus
uh the next uh couple months later i was
one of the hardest trainers
at nautilus there in sandy springs so
it's it's
this is like this is a movie the first
act this is the first act where the kid
goes and he
picks up the quarter and he sees a
hundred dollar bill and his booze like i
don't know what should i do with it well
you want to be a movie star don't you
he's like well yeah but i could buy a
lot of pizza and a lot of
other cool things with this it's like
okay i guess you're not gonna be a movie
star
and then he looks across the street and
there's a freaking gym
and after three years and the kid goes
there which most kids won't ever go
they won't do that i wouldn't have done
that i would have taken 100 bucks and i
would have bought a colecovision
i would have bought whatever and and i
just i i don't have that you
that's amazing i remember when you first
got smallville well when i first got
when we first got smallville i had it
sounds fancy
but it wasn't five thousand dollar
cadillac el dorado
uh convertible that didn't run very well
it looked good but it was a piece of
[ __ ] i bought it for five grand
and you let me keep it at your mansion
if i may say
uh in agora hills i lost it don't don't
let him kid you i lost it folks i lost
it but you had one
that's more than i had a jet too i lost
that too all right well
you know we could talk about that but
right now i'm talking about my shitty el
dorado catalonic convertible john el
dorado what was like from smoking the
bandit yeah i remember you came over one
day
you have i don't know if you had any
more but you had the general lee
in your garage yeah i do i have i have
two of them now okay
so i go okay i see it and you're like
yeah and i was kind of nervous asking
you
and you're like let's go for a ride and
we got in
of course i jumped through the window it
was hard because i just had surgery a
few years back so i was a little stiff
but we drove down the highway and we got
looks and the girls i was like oh my
gosh
generally some people that were younger
were like what the hell are these guys
but it was my brother i got my brother
it was before facetime he was like no
way
it was so exciting but you're so giving
you're so good to me
you eventually said come get your piece
of [ __ ] i can't keep it here anymore but
i it was after about a year or two and i
understood that but you know those days
did you have a great time doing the show
did you love doing the show did you uh
i mean i i could tell that you were just
really enveloped sort of in the
in the role you took it so seriously
which i think really helped the
character
in the show well thank you uh yeah i
have uh i have
you know it's been a long time so i have
i have great
great memories uh another part of me
remembers though being kind of pissy
about
scripts or about uh
the shallowness of uh of
the writing at times but you know now i
realize you know
it's hard it's hard to turn out 24
stories worth watching a year
it's hard to do that so yeah uh but i
didn't i didn't really know
and i just did a youtube video um
i do i answer duke's questions and
people always ask me my favorite episode
and somebody said what is your least
favorite episode
and i had to tell them that when we did
it we did one called the ghost of
general lee
and i remember reading it and thinking
oh great now we're stealing from mark
twain this is tom sawyer we show up at
our own wake i mean these guys are so
lame years later it became my favorite
episode
so once i became a member of the
audience
rather than a member of the cast i loved
every minute of dukes
um but i'd be lying if i didn't say i
didn't piss and moan a little bit during
our
during our seven years i think we all
did look i mean you're you're caught up
in it you're tired you're working and
i think everybody did such a fantastic
job that we were always pushing each
other in different ways and
so you know you always want the this to
be better that to be better and
nothing's perfect so you do the best you
can and of course i look now and i'm
like
to write 22 24 episode one hours a year
how could how could more than half of
them even be good
it's so hard that you hope you haven't
you know i work now i've worked out for
the last
seven eight seven years eight years
anyway with tyler perry tyler turns out
22 24 episodes of the haves and
have-nots a year
24 episodes of six other shows a year
somehow he manages to uh to write them
and direct them and and uh
it's called speed speed the hardest
and easiest schedule i've ever had is
doing the haves and have nots
we have shot we shoot between 100 and
140 pages
a day screw that i wouldn't do it i'd
fall apart i can't memorize
i need i need a week to do five pages
yeah well yes i won't see you on the set
well
you know by the way my mother said wow
he just
plays a real evil character on that have
and have nots wow he's so
dark and i'm like did you do that
purposely like i think as actors
sometimes we're like going
we're playing such a a nice you know a
genuinely innately good person on
smallville and then it'll suddenly just
you want to turn it around and say hey
look at me i could do something
different
was there part of that well again there
was uh after smallville there was uh
i did a wheel on niptuck
yep uh and then i did a show called
dirty sexy money
oh yeah then i did i did an episode of
leverage which was great
so all of a sudden again recognizing
opportunities all of a sudden these
characters started to
change a little bit well quite a bit for
me but these darker things started
coming in
so when the haves and have-nots when i
read that and i had to read for it you
read by
by invitation for tyler um
i read it and again i said
oh there it is there's the next one
and uh so i went in and i i
was like this is mine i don't know i
don't know why anybody else is
is here uh maybe they didn't have
anything to do today but this is mine
months later when i had kind of
forgotten about the whole thing i got
the call that yeah we're going to do
this show and uh you're going to atlanta
and it's going to be great
so um and it's been it's been wonderful
but again
that was that thing that i recognized
and said oh
you know again i'm a 13 year old oh
there it is there's the next stepping
stone do you ever get nervous do you
ever get nervous while you're acting you
ever get nervous about
you and by the way who helps you learn
lines you learn them quickly how do you
do that
i learn quickly i don't get nervous
anymore i i really you know michael i
i don't get nervous why what's the
secret
um knowing that the part is yours
i remember i did a thing uh i went and
read for rob reiner
or something and it was i thought oh
this is great this is this is me it was
a lot like smallville though and there
were dark things coming
but dark things coming that's a good
title
um but i read for rob reiner and uh
found out a couple days later that
somebody else got it and my first
thought and this is not
my new york sarcasm my first thought was
wow i thought reiner was smarter than
that i
you know what i know john schneider
enough to say i could have told you
you'd say that
you're definitely one where it's it's i
like it it's an ego but it's like you
know you
believe so much in yourself that you're
like matt wrong decision i know what i
can
and it's not even what i can do i know
what i can bring and what i bring
is believability so if you want
if you want people to believe the [ __ ]
that you wrote
then you've got to have someone who can
convince people the [ __ ] that you wrote
is real
i'm that guy i'll note that i tell i've
taught a couple of acting classes when
people
when the teachers couldn't be there and
i say we're throwing out all this check
off in shakespeare and we're no neil
simon for god's sake we're not going to
do neil simon
because neil simon is brilliant the
chance that you will ever have the
opportunity to be the first person
to utter align the likes of which neil
simon wrote
is slim to none however
your job is to make atrocious dialogue
believable so let's find some atrocious
dialogue
and make it believable yeah that's what
i teach or do it the best you can i've
had some atrocious dialogue in my time
and uh you know i remember being on a
show where
even my own family was like wow that's
bad
and i'm like what oh my god my own
family
i'm like i'm trying like i'm at night
i'm like what can i do you can't do
anything
you just can't you just could do your
best it's a 20 watt bulb it's a 20 watt
bulb you can't make it burn at 60.
you just can't you can make it the best
finely polished turd that you can
inside of you is brought to you by
hydrant summer's here guys
and i'm always dehydrated i never drink
enough water ryan it's crazy freaking
hot
outside well no i decided to wear pants
that was a bad idea bad idea man i'm
always wearing shorts
and i'm still dehydrated it's terrible
but i started taking these powders
these electrolyte powders by hydrant
look we all know that we have to drink
more water
but by the time you feel thirsty it's
too late you're already dehydrated you
can't focus
you feel tired and it's critical it's
critical to drink more water
hydrant has created a refreshing
electrolyte powder that you mix directly
into water
to more efficiently and effectively
hydrate your body it hydrates you
quickly
and keeps you going for longer it helps
me i'm older i need this stuff i need to
keep going and i forget
like on this podcast i talked to
somebody for an hour and a half hi drent
gotta hydrate myself and what i love is
it's backed by research
it's not just another product hydrant is
a formula that was created
developed by an oxford scientist it also
is loved by pro athletes celebrities top
performers and
has thousands of five star reviews
it's made with real fruit juice powder
delicious refreshing
comes in a variety of flavors including
new summer friendly iced tea lemonade
and fruit punch
those happen to be my favorites and uh
tell them about our special deal ryan we
got a special deal for listeners to save
25 off their first order go to drink
hydrant dot com
slash inside or enter the promo code
inside
at checkout that's
d-r-i-n-k-h-y-d-r-a-n-t
dot com slash inside and enter promo
code
inside for 25 off your first order
drink hydrant.com inside enter the promo
code inside to save 25
and we thank them for sponsoring our
podcast
thank you hydrant inside of you is
brought to you by lucy
i needed this company to come along i'm
so glad it did lucy nicotine is a
company founded by caltech scientists
and former smokers looking for a better
and cleaner nicotine alternative finally
tobacco alternatives that don't
suck research for three years developed
for people
not patients lucy has created a nicotine
gum with four milligrams of nicotine
that comes in three flavors
wintergreen cinnamon pomegranate
lucy has a lozenge with four milligrams
of nicotine and cherry ice flavor if
that's what you prefer
ryan how about yourself you're not a
smoker i'm not no i just
i just end up having to cut out a lot of
your hacks and wheezes on the podcast
but not anymore
not anymore not with these lozenges
that's exactly this is good for me too
thank you
you've helped ryan lucy it's 2020 get
off your cigarettes unplug your vape
throw away your dip that's what we call
a dip in the midwest
get some lucy nicotine gum or lozenges
this is the real deal
a subscription to lucy comes directly to
your door each month
it's so simple and you don't have to
leave your house because lucy has
delivery down
listeners go to lucy.co and use promo
code inside to get 20
off all products including gum or
lozenges that's lucy.co and use
promo code inside at checkout also i
have to give this disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical
lucy.co and be sure to use that promo
code
inside inside of you is brought to you
by quip
i love these toothbrushes they're
they're good looking
they work so well they're easy to travel
with
they're reasonably priced i mean these
electric toothbrushes man they cost you
a fortune and you get stopped at
security in the airplane like what's in
there
that's my toothbrush you know what i
mean does that happen it has happened i
have a big
toothbrush thing but not anymore because
i have quip smart electric toothbrushes
have all the guiding features of our
original brush with a new
bluetooth smart motor that connects to
the free quip
app so you can track your brushing you
can get tips and daily coaching
and earn rewards for good habits like
brushing two minutes
twice a day and the quick brushes are
for kids or adults
so you have both earn daily points for
brushing two minutes twice a day
earn bonus points for challenges like
streaks it's just pretty much amazing
they're pretty much saying brush your
teeth
and get rewarded for it quip's got all
sorts of features a built-in two-minute
timer it pulses every 30 seconds to
remind you to
switch sides and help you clean your
whole mouth effectively
evenly kid's electric toothbrush is just
like our original but with size down
features
anti-cavity toothpaste and a mint or
watermelon flavor
and uh tooth strengthening fluoride plus
you can get brush heads toothpaste and
floss refills delivered from five
dollars and shipping is free
how smart is that join over five million
mouths who use quip and save hundreds
compared to other bluetooth brushes
when you get a quip smart brush for just
dollars start getting rewards for
brushing your teeth today
and go to getquip.com you
right now to get your first refill free
that's your first refill free
at getquip.com you spelt
g e t q u i p dot com
slash y o u quip
better oral health made simple and
rewarding
what's the hardest thing you've gone
through in your life i mean obviously a
lot but what's the one that just
resonates at the hardest moment in your
life where it was just uh you thought
you know and i don't know what you
thought if you can get through this or
well when my smile when alicia uh a year
and a half ago now was diagnosed with
stage four
uh breast cancer oh
oh i'm sorry now she's clean she's clean
we attacked that that's just the most
amazing thing about alicia we are so
similar
and yet we are we we both come to this
relationship this marriage with
with a full toolbox full of tools
but neither one of us have the same
tools
because i like to say if if uh if if two
of us are the same then one of us is
unnecessary
so when uh when a person in a white coat
told us that she was three years into a
five-year shelf life
and her pet scan lit up like a christmas
tree
we both and hear this folks we both
looked at each other and said
no we have things to do
not only individually but together we
have a tremendous
amount of things to to do this is not
going to happen to us
we are going to figure out everything
that cancer
wants and stop it we are going to find
out
everything that cancer hates and do it
and we did and now she has a clear pet
scan
and she cancer is by the way cancer is
not something you beat
cancer is something uh i know this
because i'm the founder of the
co-founder of children's miracle network
cancer is something we all have but we
also all have
a system that is built to fight it to
keep it at bay it's like
oil and water you know it's gotta you've
got to keep it at bay
so when somebody in a white coat tells
you you have cancer
what they really are saying is your
cancer has gotten stronger and your
system
that fights it has gotten weaker or has
given up
so you have got to
weaken the cancer while strengthening
that system
how do you do that well you do it with
diet you do it with i mean people say
cancer can't live in a uh
in uh alco and alkalinity so drink
alkaline water well yeah do that
cancer can't live in heat so
get a uh every opportunity do infrared
get into an infrared uh sauna infrared
saunas go up to 158 degrees
i have one of those cancer loves sugar
when you get a pet scan they will give
you a thing called glucose so that they
can see where the cancer is
why because cancer attracts glucose
so stop eating sugar it's not a matter
of choice it's a matter of it's a matter
of
absolutely a matter of life and death uh
there's something about cbd oil
that helps i don't think it fights
cancer but i think
it takes your system that is there to
fight cancer
and gives it something it can recognize
and that system goes oh
thank god you're here where you've been
and it enables that system
to get stronger it enables i believe
that enables the medicine that the
doctors will give you
to work better so the second that person
in a white coat walks in
and says these things your mind you
don't i mean do you get emotional do you
start going oh why are you just turn
yeah i mean i can't even think about it
without without getting him because i
mean i was there
and um alicia puts it this way she said
for
for the first couple of days let the
house be on fire
you know you woke up in the middle of
the night and there's there's flames
down in the hallway and there's no way
to get out except jump out the window
and it's three stories okay we'll live
that way for a couple of days
don't don't deny yourself
the cleansing
of panic but don't
live there you can't live there
it almost sounds like she's consoling
you in a way she's like saying hey this
is
like almost she's like she was i don't
know there's
this inner strength where i think i
would just fall apart i wouldn't
and she's like hey this is it's almost
like you guys jumped into a plan like
we've got to get this let's grieve let's
see we panicked we panicked and
uh you know all these all these
long-term goals i couldn't look at it
couldn't look at a tree i couldn't look
at a flower i couldn't look at anything
without wondering if she was going to be
here
to because we plant we do a lot of
plantings and things plant plant things
planting and uh yeah gardening is great
for the soul
um so everything
made me sad for a little while
uh nothing made me mad you can't get mad
because if you realize
cancer is something we all have just
some of us
have stopped fighting it for some reason
well figure that reason out
and fix it so
so that was hard but we were strong
together before
you know now i mean we're johnny and
june
it was on last night i watched walking
phoenix that it
just came on i was like oh look at that
you know i remember when you um when
your dad passed
and i remember you made a v there was
like a video because you i don't know if
you're on a photo shoot i can't remember
exactly but i remember how emotional it
was and
but you wanted you wanted to remember it
so you filmed it how'd that go
well we were doing a press shoot for
habs and have nots
and during lunch i had my dad
had a stroke and he was in bad shape and
uh he passed away during lunch and i had
a couple of more
setups to do and when
they had said this was this is your last
one so when
i said let me know when you when you
take the last picture he said don't
worry i'll get you out of here
it's not about that just let me know and
um
he said okay all right that was it and i
said come here take my picture
and he said no we're done i said no no
just take my picture and i'll tell you
why
and he took this series of like 38 chin
chin pictures
and then i told him i said i i learned
during
lunch that my father had passed away
and i wanted
for some reason it was almost like you
know
god said capture that moment and i did
and later that that gentleman asked if
he could publish those pictures and i
saw them and they were
they were you can't act that
um and i said absolutely you know go
ahead
uh because i believe that when you see
again like you
don't deny yourself panic don't deny
yourself
grief so
that was on display and
somewhere during the next year
that photographers he was doing a shoot
and he found out
that his brother had died and he turned
to his assistant
handed him the camera and said take my
picture
what oh my god
and i have i have the pictures just from
my cell phone
uh within three minutes of finding out
my mother had passed away
and there's there's something healing
about
those pictures and i'm not sure what it
is
but uh if you have that opportunity
it's not a selfish thing it's not a
narcissistic thing
capture that moment so here's why i'm
just figuring this out
so you can always remember how much you
love
them i just thought that because i think
sometimes when you lose something
and you know someone passes or this
like you know i should be you know did i
grieve
long enough did i you know and you start
to question things like why didn't i
and it's it's a moment like that that
makes you realize look you absolutely
love this person
i can look at those pictures on my phone
and they're not for anybody else or just
for me um
but it's it's a good idea it's a good
thing to do
uh it'll it'll uh yeah like you said
like we said it'll keep it it'll remind
you how much you love
them um speaking of which you care if i
play this
little song it's my favorite song it was
the number one hit that you did
oh sure sure
[Music]
oh that when you played that for me and
on smallville i go
holy [ __ ] this guy does it all
uh all right this is called [ __ ] talking
with john schneider my patrons who i
love who support the show so much
these are some questions from them so
this is rapid fire you don't have to sit
here and dive deep if you don't want to
uh steph a were you offended by the
dukes of hazard with a film with jessica
simpson or did you like it
uh i thought it would have to be
considerably better to suck
there you go thank you nancy d you've
had such a varied and lengthy career
how have you stayed so grounded with
such incredible credits on your resume
because i know i'm not uh i know i'm not
there yet
um i can i can see the finish line from
here but
in many regards i feel this is uh i mean
this i feel like i'm i've just started
wow you have that attitude man you have
to have that attitude
it's not like athletics you know
somebody is faster than somebody else
somebody throws a ball faster than
somebody else somebody hits a puck
more accurately than somebody else with
us it's all relative it's all
speculation so you've got to have your
own
unit of measure and uh
i've hit a couple of triples but i
haven't hit the grand slam yet
but i will i love the attitude carly h
how difficult was it playing jonathan
kent
when you knew there was a time limit on
his involvement in the show and did this
affect the choices you made in playing
him
uh the way i the way i played jonathan
kent was mostly affected by the fact
that my son
uh real son uh had has asperger's
syndrome
so um i chose to treat jason
as if he was someone who had special
gifts
not special needs and we talked about
that on smallville a lot because
we had to forget that this boy was going
to be superman because superman didn't
exist yet
wow so uh so there
my death my impending death never even
occurred to me all right
anna a what prompted you to found
co-found the children's miracle network
how much are you still active with the
organization
i'm still very active with children's
miracle network although we're doing
things
uh in cyber land like like this now
but um when i was a kid when i was a fat
kid i had asthma i had an inhaler
i spent a lot of time uh in hospitals
being poked and prodded
when dukes of hazard happened and i
became
i was on the number one show in a three
network world
um i felt the need to do something
so that children wouldn't have to go
through what i went through
when i was a kid and that's how
children's miracle network was
was burst really well makes perfect
sense uh
jennifer ann she grew up watching dukes
of hazzard and loves the song good old
boys what is your favorite episode in
the show i think you said that
yeah my favorite i'll tell you my
favorite episode is ghost of general lee
however
i had so much fun doing carnival thrills
also doing go west young dukes because i
got to i got to have a mustache and a
bull whip and
you know a gun i didn't have to carry a
bow and arrow in my pocket it's kind of
hard to carry a bone in your pocket
so those would be my top three lisa h
what was more brutal on you mentally
starring in a weekly tv show or your
stint on dancing with the stars
my stand on dancing with the stars is
the single most difficult thing i have
ever done in my life
and i've been on broadway i've played
music for 120
000 people i've done all these
television shows but dancing with the
stars kicked
my ass all right hey i wanted to ask you
know i never got
i think i'm asking you not because it
was terrible time in your life but maybe
it's selfish of me to ask this because
it's always scared me
but you you had to go to jail for a
couple days right
well i was supposed to go for three but
the jail was full so i went for nine
hours
nine hours well but there's an important
important thing to know there
okay i went for three and when you go in
you go in when you're processed into the
twin towers in la
you're processed into the twin towers in
la you are
make no mistake you are in jail and i
was fully
believing i was going to be there for
three solid days because that's what
my ex-wives uh
lawyer made sure that the judge checked
some box
um so in my mind i was there for three
days i was
shocked uh
and you know oddly enough michael you'll
believe this i don't think anybody else
will believe it
i was looking forward to the research
i was going to be doing for three days
in jail
and when they let me out i was like wait
a minute are you are you sure
i mean do i have to come back no no you
you're out you you
you came you had every intention of
doing your three days there's no room
so you're dude they're letting you out
you aren't nervous at all
you aren't you you honestly when you
first went into that i was in court
because in
in court i said earlier i don't get
nervous well i got nervous in court
because i realized
that this judge for whatever reason um
didn't like me and
really i don't know if he had a
relationship with the with
my my wife's uh counsel or what but he
they would do the most atrocious things
and say the worst the terrible things
and he would just sit there and listen
and i would say something
in defense of myself and i was treated
like
i was treated terribly so
i was treated in jail much better than i
was treated in court
in court i was treated like i was guilty
until proven innocent wow so whatever
anybody you know when somebody says you
know i was framed and they did
believe them because
i found no justice whatsoever
in the court in los angeles at 111 high
street
no justice whatsoever you know me
michael i'm
i'm i mean i will try to do the right
thing
but when you push me to a certain point
especially when you call me a liar
my god so i asked when it was all when
it was all over
he gave me a date i had to report to
jail by a certain certain time and i
said your honor
i want to get this behind me can you
just send me now
he said what i said you told me before
that you know if
if i didn't show up you're going to
track me down and have a bench warrant
for me and throw me in jail
well it can't be that difficult so just
send me now i want to get this over with
i want to start my three days
as soon as i get out of here i want to
walk to jail and get this over with
what did he say he said um bayless can
we do that
no one's ever said it this guy's lost
his mouth no no one's ever done that
before and this is a guy who threatened
to throw me and you know come across the
state
come across the country and throw me in
jail
so he had a sense of humor about it and
i went to jail and they weren't ready
for me i had to ask i had to beg i said
look i got the paperwork here
said i love the show which one
but i had to i had to request that
the the uh the deputies call the court
and figure out how to admit me into jail
and they did and they said okay well
come on in and took the shoelaces took
the belt took i mean did the whole thing
and i was you know waiting for an orange
jumpsuit
right and uh wound up being let go
right if you guys don't know the story
obviously this is taken out of context
but it was like you know uh
obviously you know you have you know the
story your your whole ranch your movie
studio was completely
like trashed right from the for
hurricanes during that time yeah where
i'm standing right now
yeah the water water was this high you
really can't get much of a
of a picture of that here right
everything i had in the world
uh was destroyed two thousand what is
today
on august 13 2016
and we had just had in march we had had
the hundred year flood
so we lost a lot of things in march but
it was nothing
compared to what happened in august and
so that's pretty much why you're saying
you were you were you had no money to
give or you would have given it
well i had nothing my tax returns proved
beyond the shadow of a doubt
that i had lost almost a half a million
dollars
in 2016. okay
the lawyers on the other side talked to
the the i had the third time i had to
bring the the cpa out who prepared my
tax returns
and i thought it was all going to be
over at that point we'll hear the tax
returns their tax returns
they're undeniable well she said to the
uh to the cpa
excuse me did you prepare that you
prepared the tax return she said yes
she said and the receipts that the tax
returns were prepared from
did you compile those yourself and she
said well no
and she said it's here say your honor
and my piece of [ __ ] lawyer
didn't say just a moment your honor i
when i uh
uh cross-examined me i say all he had to
do
was say do you know the person who
prepared the receipts and she would have
said known her all my life
or known her for 20 years he didn't do
it wow
so the judge said and this is why i this
is why i have bad feelings toward you
judge he
said people lie on their taxes all the
time sustained
at that moment my tax returns proving i
didn't have two
nickels to rub together were
inadmissible
and i now was a guy who had millions of
dollars
who would not pay it and that's why i
went to jail
what a story i can't wait to read the
next book but i put it in a script i put
i put a lot of that in the script you
know
there's a as the uh the optimist said
looking at a pile of [ __ ] he said you
know there's a pony in there somewhere
so uh
[Laughter]
i love you michael dude listen i love
you i mean i i'm amazed you're so open
and so honest and so
sincere and i love hearing all these
stories and i mean we talk about your
success and
it's amazing what when people listen you
know a lot of these stories
you know i think it gives them hope and
you opening up about your wife
and the cancer is just inspirational and
uh let me throw one more thing at you
michael i think this is important
um all this
my life has been great i love i love
every minute even the bad stuff and
here's why
if you know you're a hockey player if
you have the puck
and nobody's on your ass then you're not
a threat
so if you don't have problems like this
if you don't have a judge to look at and
go am i speaking some
language you don't understand if you
don't have those things to me
those things that try to stop me let me
know
that i am indeed on the right track
if i didn't have those things i would
question whether or not whether or not
i was on the right track so if there's
somebody out there right now
who just just gets piled on them
don't let that weaken you let that give
you strength
to get through it because there's
something up there around that next
corner
that somebody doesn't want you to see
go for it with everything you've got
i love it hey this is awesome i'm glad
we finally found an
area where you where i could see you and
i can hear
you again i'm going to come down and
visit that place it looks great
please do you love it michael you'd love
it this has been real nice
it's been amazing to catch up on your
dreams and bring them here and get them
get them
put some light on them i will johnny
good talking to you love you michael
the one thing you gotta love about john
is he says what he wants to say
and what he feels he doesn't uh kind of
like people will call me and say
cut that do this he's like air i want
you to air this i want you to air this
the judge was an idiot you know and uh
it's just you know he just kind of
what's the saying you uh
go by your own tune of your
hormones well that too but you go
the beat of your own drum to beat her
your own bongos man whatever
i'm never meant for uh clever things uh
i want to say thanks again to everybody
listening and keep listening it's big
announcement
with westwood one which is incredible
they bought the show and
they're so amazing over there they're
really rocking it everybody over there
thank you
i have sales meetings now when i have
meetings about the show
and the guests and it was just
me and bryce and ryan going hey i'm
interviewing him okay let's do it
and which is great but now hopefully
this is this is definitely the next
level they're a big company
and they really support the podcast and
i and i really want to give a shout out
again to westwood one for supporting us
and
and believing in us and uh thank you
also support the podcast follow us
subscribe it helps so much we're really
getting more subscriptions and if you
like this guest you know stick around
um the handles are at inside of you
podcast on instagram and facebook and
twitter's at inside of you
pod um so it really really helps
i told you about the virtuals make sure
you watch the virtual uh
cons we do q and a's we do duo
zooms me and tom and single zooms with
me and
you know you only get a certain amount
of time but i'm always pressing the more
time button for people
and they're like rosy mom we got to move
on i go i know but these people are
they're paying for a zoom i want to you
know give them a little bit talk to them
and
so check those out and uh yeah i'm on
the cameo i think that's it let me uh
uh shout out to all my shout outs the uh
the patrons of course can't forget the
most important
nancy d mary b leah s trisha f sarah v
little lisa yukiko jill e brian h
brian lauren g nico p
barry i angelina g robin asked jerry w
just heard from jerry w hi jerry he
cameoed me emily k
bob b robert b jason w stephen j kristen
k amelia o allison l
thomann jess j lucas m raj
everybody knows raj joshua d emily s
cjp samantha m humza b
so easy to say that hamza jennifer n
stacy b carly t jennifer s janelle b
tabitha 272 kimberly e crystal h
mika e i'm sorry mike e mike
e marissa n nanidello ramirez
beth b chris f chad w lemp jackie p
rodrigo
s rachen ray a maya p megan d jennifer c
maddie s tiffany i kendrick f
ashley e margie m thomas t matt w
belinda n
benjamin r lisa j kevin v robert s joy w
nicole m amber f james r chris h snow
r snow noah k and sean
v those are the patrons giving extra
support to the podcast
and uh i love it so hey guys be safe out
there love your dogs love your
family give them a call text it's so
easy to say i love you you never know
what's gonna happen
um and we've got a lot of great guests
coming up so please stick around
uh all my love thanks to ryan here
thanks to bryce thanks to westwood one
and everyone else thank you for allowing
me to get inside each and every one of
you
until next time